Arizona's senior senator john mccain is
recovering from surgery this morning and
that means the senate will not get to
vote on health care anytime soon john
mccain had a blood clot removed from
above his left eye on friday
republican leaders have called off this
week scheduled vote on their bill to
replace obamacare nancy coordinates is
on capitol hill where that delay could
stretch out longer than a week Nancy
good morning to you good morning and
Senate Republican leaders really had no
choice with McCain gone they simply did
not have the votes to even bring this
bill to the Senate floor and so over the
weekend Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell announced that while John is
recovering the Senate will defer
consideration of the better care act but
a delay could further imperil this bill
already two Republicans Susan Collins
and Rand Paul have announced their
opposition and about a dozen others are
still undecided they're waiting to see
how the nonpartisan Congressional Budget
Office analyzes this bill now GOP
leaders were pushing the CBO to release
its review as early as today but now
that the vote is delayed looks like CBO
is going to take a little more time as
well and what senators want to know in
particular is how the CBO will review a
new provision from Ted Cruz that would
allow insurers to offer cheaper
bare-bones plants to the healthy over
the weekend the nation's largest
insurers released a letter calling the
Cruz proposal unworkable in any form and
saying it would increase premiums for
those with pre-existing conditions and
lead to widespread terminations of
coverage now senators want to know if
the CBO shares that view